So does that mean and forgive me if I'm
wrong again does that mean that any sort
of sickness such as cancer and stuff is
that given if if God wants to take
control is that given from God or
>> no not always
>> brother the Bible has every answer to
every question you have but that's no
that's not it some diseases are the
result of Satan demons inflicting you
>> in order to get you to doubt God and
curse God some diseases are simply the
result of the fall because our bodies
are broken. So broken bodies, decayed
bodies, bodies that have [clears throat]
cancer cells and other
deficiencies do not produce perfect
physical bodies. So sometimes you're
born with the genetic disposition for
diabetes. Why? Because your parents have
diabetes.
>> Yeah,
>> you get my point. Sometimes you're born
with a genetic disposition for
particular cancer because it runs in
your family. That's the result of broken
bodies. Broken bodies cannot produce
perfect bodies, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, some diseases are satanic, demonic.
Some are just the result of the fall.
Some can be God's punishment.
>> Okay.
>> But I don't know which because I'm not
God. Right.
>> Of course. Yeah. And obviously we assume
for kids that it's not punishment. So,
it's just um it's mainly maybe it's
maybe it's just God thinking he wants
them now or it's obviously God doesn't
need to explain why
>> the Bible says a child dies under the
grace of Jesus, the mercy of Jesus
covered by the blood of Jesus. Children
don't enter to heaven without Jesus.
They enter heaven because Jesus
loves them and saves them. So, it
doesn't matter. No one enters heaven
without Jesus.
>> Absolutely. Every child enters heaven
because Jesus procured their salvation.
By his blood on the cross, he covered
all of them.
>> Exactly.
>> They only enter because Jesus loves them
and has made them the greatest in the
kingdom. Now,
>> correct.
>> Speaking of disease,
>> because you're asking me about disease.
All right. Here you go.
>> The man born blind. John 9 1 and three.
>> As he passed by, he saw a man blind from
birth. And his disciples asked him,
saying, "Rabbi, who sin? this man or his
parents that he would be born blind.
Jesus answered, "Neither this man nor
his parents sin,
but this was so that the works of God
might be manifested in him." So he
wasn't being punished for any sin he
committed in the womb.
>> Yeah.
>> Or punished because of his parents sin.
He was just born blind, a defect as a
result of broken and perfect bodies,
conceiving broken and imperfect
human bodies.
And the Lord then using that blindness
to glorify his name. Okay. So the man
wasn't blind because of punishment of
sin. Right.
>> Yeah. It was solely for for Jesus to
manifest in him.
>> Okay. Now the man who was paralyzed and
healed by Jesus.
He healed the man a paralytic. John
5:14. Look at what Jesus says. Afterward
Jesus found him in the temple and said
to him, "Behold, you've become well. Do
not sin anymore so that nothing worse
happens to you." Oh, so some diseases
are the result of sin and being punished
for it.
>> Correct. Yeah.
>> You see, now
>> sin. If you sin, then it's going to
happen is what he's saying. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He's saying something worse will
happen. So, do
>> diseases
occur because of punishment for
unconfessed sins, unrepentant sins? Yes.
>> Does that mean all diseases? No.
>> No.
>> Okay, we got it.
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Okay. Well, let's go a little deeper.
Take it to be patient, man. Tech, I know
you shrimp on the barbie.
>> You have to come to Australia, Sam. You
know, you have a huge family. Shrimp on
a barber. There you go. James 5:13-16.
Is anyone among you suffering? Then he
must pray. Is anyone cheerful? He is to
sing praises. Is anyone among you sick?
Then he must call for the elders of the
church. And they are to pray over him,
anointing him with the oil in the name
of the Lord. And the prayer offered in
faith will save the one who is sick and
the Lord will raise him up. And if he
has committed sins, they'll be forgiven
him. Did you catch it?
>> Yeah.
>> The man or the woman may be sick as a
result of unconfessed sin that they
haven't confessed, acknowledged, turn
away from. So God to get their attention
has afflict them with a disease so that
they can realize and repent and be
forgiven. Therefore, confess your sins
to one another and pray for one another
so that you may be healed. [snorts]
>> The effective prayer of a righteous man
can accomplish much.
>> We got it so far.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Can I give you a few more examples that
some diseases can be punishment of sin?
>> Sure.
>> You sure?
>> Absolutely. I'm loving it. If I'm If I'm
not wasting your time.
>> No. No. You don't waste my time,
brother. I'm I'm just They stuffed me.
They made me 10 pounds fatter this two
weeks and I'm like a butterball. So I
know all that work that I did to get to
97. I'm now like 240 went out the
window. So I got to get back again. So
that means I go back to the drawing
drawing board. Lord strengthen my
throat. Okay. Are you ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Deuteronomy 285861. Warning to Israel.
If you're not careful to do all the
words of this law which are written the
book, this book to fear is this glorious
and fierce name, Yahweh your God, then
Yahweh will bring wondrous plagues on
you. Notice what the punishment will be.
>> Plagues.
>> Plagues,
>> diseases,
plagues on those who are your seed, even
great and enduring plagues and miserable
enduring sicknesses like bubanic plague
or manufactured ones like I I can't say
it. I may get banned. He will bring upon
back on you all the disease of Egypt of
which you were afraid and they will
cling to you also every sickness and
every plague which is not written in the
book of this law Yahweh will bring on
you until you are destroyed. So did God
just say
>> some diseases a result of punishment for
sin?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> You see it right there. What did he say?
If you don't obey the commandment,
Yahweh will bring plagues on you.
>> Plagues on you. Yeah. es on you
>> and miserable and enduring sickness and
wow miserable enduring
>> so HIV God's punishment for a wicked
evil filthy immoral lifestyle how do I
know
>> correct let me show you
how do I know statistics have shown and
proven statistics all right
>> have shown
>> so technically
>> what
>> so technically we're all like not no
We're we're wrong when we blame Satan
for all these things technically, right?
For old
>> God. You can't blame Satan for every
disease. But you can't even blame God
for diseases. Why? Because God does not
will wolffully afflict anyone unless
it's because of sin.
>> Yeah.
>> So even if you want to blame God and
let's say God allowed that to come upon
you, it doesn't always mean God did it
directly. So you're asking me a very
complicated question. God can remove his
hand of protection and allow Satan to
come and mess up your life and inflict
you with disease.
>> Yeah.
>> So, God didn't do it. Satan didn't. But
God allowed him
because you're now in sin that you
haven't confessed
and you're doubling down in your sinful
lifestyle no matter how many time God
tries to warn you and wake you up. So
God says your punishment now is Satan
will come and mess your life up and
wreck havoc and bring all hell upon you.
>> Yes. So, Satan is the one who's
afflicting you, but that affliction from
Satan is because God has now allowed it
because he's going to use Satan to
punish you.
>> Exactly. Yeah. The the same way God
allowed Satan to test Job basically.
>> Yep. But who brought the punishment, the
death, the murder, the disease? Satan
and his agents, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And Satan even used humans.
>> Right. Okay. So, Satan doesn't always do
directly. He used human agents like to
come and rob and you get it. Point being
>> sometimes it's directly the hand of God.
Sometimes it's not the hand of God. It's
the hand of others that God allows. Then
the question becomes why did God allow
him? In the case of
>> Job, it was not because of punishment
for sin.
>> Yeah. Different situation.
>> Because he was going to prove Satan a
liar that Job only loves God because of
the blessing. No, God loves me and I
love God for who God is. I love God for
who God is. Now, nonetheless, here you
go.
Therefore, Romans 1:24:32, God gave them
over in the lust of their hearts
impurity, so that their bodies would be
dishonored among them. For they
exchanged the truth of God for a lie.
Instead of worshiping God and acting
upon the truth that he revealed to them,
they followed their own desires and
lusts, perverted thoughts and started
worshiping and serving creatures
rather than the creator who's blessed
forever. Amen. Now, how do you worship
the creature? You see it all around you
today. You have people who worship movie
stars, athletes and singers. And sadly,
even among Christianity, you have the
cult of personality where Christians who
know who should know better end up
idolizing and worshiping their
apologists, their teachers. Sadly, there
are people in the crowd that worship me.
God forbid.
>> They
>> don't realize they're worshiping me. But
when they blindly
>> follow me and parrot me and never
question me or look for a second
opinion, they are worshiping me,
>> not because I want them to.
>> I guess it's especially with worship, it
can be like not knowing. You might not
know that you're worshiping, but even if
you're like special kids,
>> the responsibility of a teacher,
brother, is to remind you and make you
aware of cult of personality
and remind you and make you aware you
cannot cling to one individual and swear
by every word that proceeds out of his
mouth.
>> Yeah.
And and and you would say it's the same
for even like as as as men or boys, you
could say teenagers. If if we're on the
game 24/7, that game is replacing
personal time personal time with God.
You're worshiping that.
>> That's an idol man. Idol brother. But my
point is that's how you worship the
creature.
>> Yeah.
>> You may not know you're worshiping the
creature because you don't think you're
worship creature, but when you got a
person
>> that idolizes Michael Jordan, so I'm
dating myself because no one else date
me, so I'm dating myself. or idolizes
Bruce Lee or and they got like me as a
>> James.
>> Yeah.
>> You get my point?
>> That's worship, man. But now what does
God do though when they worship the
creature instead of
>> and then notice the connection and this
cult of personality or
in this idolization of athletes or movie
star singers notice hand in hand is a
decrepit immoral lifestyle.
Mhm.
>> All of these athletes and movie stars
and singers, they live grossly immoral
lifestyles, sexual perversions,
hedonism, sensual pleasures,
drunkenness, high body counts. And
that's exactly what Romans says. They go
hand in hand.
>> Yeah.
>> Roman says this goes hand in hand.
Let me let me finish though, so you can
get the point. Yeah.
>> Because they both go hand in hand.
Idolatry, the worship of preacher,
hedonistic, immoral passions, desires,
lifestyles go hand in hand. For this
reason, God gave them over to
dishonorable passions. For their females
exchange a natural function for that
which is unnatural, lesbianism.
>> In the same way also the males abandon
natural function of the female and burn
in their desire toward one another,
males with males. Notice God says that's
unnatural. That's disordered. That's an
abomination. Mhm.
>> committing a decent act. And here's the
punishment. And receiving in their own
persons the due penalty of their error,
receiving in their bodies the punishment
of such an immoral sexual lifestyle.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah.
>> Do you understand what that means or no?
>> No. No. Yeah. Do you understand what
that meant when it said receiving in
their own persons? Meaning the
punishment
>> takes place in themselves their bodies.
>> Yeah.
>> What are STDs, buddy?
>> Yeah. It's it's it's basically a result
of that.
>> Sexually transmitted diseases, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Why is it
is predominantly the disease of
homosexuals?
Predominantly. The only way it pours
into let's say
women is because of bisexuality. Men
sleep.
But if you look at the statistics and
you look at the origin of AIDS and HIV
and you look at the ads, it's
predominantly
a disease that started among homosexuals
and their lifestyle and only passed on
because of bisexuals or because of, you
know,
Intravenous,
what they call intravenous
needles, sharing the same needle. Drug
addicts who were living homosexual
lifestyles also were addicted to drugs
and using a needle to get high out of
their mind and then using that needle or
sharing that needle.
>> Same. Yeah. Passing it on. Yeah. Yeah.
>> See how that works?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So you see how again the Bible confirms
or I should say reality confirms what
the Bible says will happen.
>> Mhm.
>> So how do I get into this rabbit?
Because I'm showing you that some
diseases are punishment from God.
>> Yes.
>> This is why statistics show and I'm
going to wrap it up with this question.
But statistics show
>> people who live
monogous lifestyles do not get sexually
transmitted diseases.
>> It's fact. Yeah.
>> If you're monogamous, one male, one
female, you don't get sexually
transmitted diseases. Those who have
high body counts and live an immoral
lifestyle, sex after sex with one
partner after another partner, not only
are they incapable of lasting
relationships, but they end up having
diseases
and other physiological
ailments that you do not find in those
who have healthy monogous relationships.
yourself.